الآن مع ظهور النتائج ليلة الانتخابات
، ينتظر الجميع
أخبار المكالمة يبدو أن الرئيس ريغان
قد فاز وقد اتصل بريغان
وهنأه عندما اتصل المرشح الرئاسي
الخاسر بالفائز للتنازل
عن الانتخابات
قبل بضع دقائق اتصلت بالرئيس
الرئيس
[موسيقى]
دونالد ترامب لضمان
الانتقال السلس للسلطة الآن بالطبع
ليس هذا دائمًا هو الحال ، فقد استدعى
نائب
الرئيس الحاكم وتراجع عن امتيازه
أنه ليس مستعدًا للتخلي عن هذا الأمر ، ولكن
ليلة الانتخابات هي مجرد بداية  ما
يمكن أن يكون في الواقع عملية طويلة جدًا
لاختيار الرئيس رسميًا
لخطر معين في عام 2020. هل
ستلتزم بالتأكد من أن هناك
انتقالًا سلميًا للسلطة
بعد الانتخابات جيدًا سنضطر
إلى رؤية ما سيحدث ، كما تعلمون  لقد
كنا نشكو بشدة
من أوراق الاقتراع التي تثير قلقي الوحيد
الذي سيحاول هذا الرئيس سرقة هذه
الانتخابات
الآن ، دعنا ندعم  ثانيًا ، عندما
تصوت لمنصب الرئيس ،
فأنت لا تفعل ذلك بشكل مباشر ، ولهذا
السبب يمكن للمرشح أن يفوز في التصويت الشعبي
ولكن ليس الرئاسة ، ما
تفعله في الواقع أنت تصوت
للناخبين ،
هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين تم تعيينهم في
كل ولاية لذلك.  اختر الرئيس
وينص القانون الفيدرالي على أن جميع النزاعات الانتخابية
على مستوى الولاية
يجب أن تنتهي بحلول الثامن من كانون الأول (ديسمبر) حتى
يتمكن الناخبون من الإدلاء بأصواتهم في
الرابع عشر من كانون الأول (ديسمبر)
والآن يتعين على كل حاكم ولاية
التصديق على أصوات الناخبين ثم
إرسالها  إلى الكونجرس ،
لذا فإن النتائج ليست رسمية حتى يقوم
المؤتمر الجديد بعد هذه الأصوات في
السادس من كانون الثاني (يناير) ، وهي
الآن عادة عملية مباشرة
ولكن دعنا نقول أن
أحد المرشحين يشكك في
شرعية إحصاء
الولاية الذي يمكن للحاكم أن يختار عدم التصديق
على  أصوات الناخبين
أو على الرغم من أن هذا غير مرجح حقًا ،
يمكن أن يقرر المجلس التشريعي للولاية
خوض
الانتخابات وإرسال عدد مختلف إلى الكونغرس
مما يعني المشاركة  يمكن أن ينتهي الأمر بالكونجرس بدون
نتائج
أو نتائج منافسة من نفس
الولاية
الآن وهذا انتهاك للقانون الفيدرالي ، لذا
لن يضطر الكونجرس بعد الآن إلى تكريم
ناخبي تلك الولاية على الإطلاق الآن
، يمكن لمجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ بعد ذلك
تحديد النتيجة الصحيحة
أو رميها
أعلم الآن أنك تعتقد أنني مجنون ولكن هذا
حدث
بالفعل كان ذلك في عام 1876 بعد فترة وجيزة من الحرب الأهلية
فاز صموئيل تيلدن في التصويت الشعبي ولكن
كان هناك 19
صوتًا انتخابيًا في النزاع ، كان على الكونغرس
التدخل والتوسط  حل وسط
تم تعيين رذرفورد هايز رئيسًا في نهاية المطاف
في مقابل إنهاء
إعادة الإعمار وانسحاب
القوات الفيدرالية من الجنوب ،
وهنا تصبح الأمور أكثر
إثارة للاهتمام إذا كان المرشح
لا يزال لا يتمتع بأغلبية
الأصوات الانتخابية بحلول نهاية هذه العملية
ينص التعديل الثاني عشر على أن مجلس
النواب يقرر
من سيكون الرئيس ويحصل كل وفد ولاية
على صوت واحد يختار مجلس الشيوخ نائب الرئيس
بصرف النظر عما يحدث ، يجب على شخص ما
أن يؤدي اليمين الدستورية في 20 يناير ،
لذا ساعدني يا إلهي إذا كان كل من الرئيس
ونائب الرئيس لا يزالان مترددين ،
فإن رئيس المنزل
يحصل مؤقتًا على هذه الوظيفة